sie geht aber noch nicht so ganz
das wird eine lange abschiedstournee
angela merkel nach fast 16 jahren durch
verbündete staaten politische gremien
medienformate sogar im
bundestagswahlkampf will sie noch
auftreten
trotz ihres satzes dass das loslassen
des alpen zum neuanfang dazu gehört ein
hinweis hält sich angela merkel bis 19
dezember im amt etwa bei die
koalitionsverhandlungen holprig werden
übertrifft sie den allzeitrekord von
helmut kohl
der schlussakkord er dauert noch in der
schlussrunde die ära merkel geht zu ende
jetzt in der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
sind sie mit mir der meinung dass es
deswegen nicht am besten wäre dass es
eben in diesem land auch weiteren eine
kanzlerin angeben soll
schauen sie ich bin der meinung dass
nach 16 jahre angela merkel die
bürgerinnen und bürger mündig genug sind
ihre entscheidung zu treffen wen sie als
kanzler möchten oder als kanzlerin ja
wahlkampfhelferin für annalena baerbock
das wollte die amtierende kanzlerin dann
doch nicht sein auf die frage der
bündnisgrüne abgeordnete ole chefs heute
nachmittag im bundestag bei der
befragung der bundeskanzlerin durch die
bundestagsabgeordneten der mutmaßlichen
letzten befragung der kanzlerin in ihrer
funktion und damit herzlich willkommen
bei uns meine gäste zunächst
zugeschaltete ruprecht polenz ist bei
uns ehemaliger generalsekretär der cdu
als angela merkel auch schon
parteivorsitzende war im jahr 2000 und
langjähriger bundestagsabgeordneter
ebenso zugeschaltet moritz kirchener
politikwissenschaftler diplom-psychologe
und redenschreiber hier im studio ist
was einer weiten feld polizistin und
autorin eines buches mit dem titel die
kanzlerin porträt einer epoche und
schließlich christoph schwennicke
publizist früher chefredakteur der
zeitschrift cicero herr polenz vor über
einem jahr haben sie gesagt wir werden
diese frau angela merkel noch sehr
vermissen
bleiben sie bei dieser einschätzung ja
sicher denn diese 16 jahre haben
deutschland gezeigt wir werden der
gleich noch darüber sprechen wie und in
welcher form und ich finde unterm strich
hat sie es gut gemacht das zeigen auch
die umfrageergebnisse die sehr über so
eine lange zeit trotz dieser schwierigen
aufgabe als beliebteste politiker
politikerin verzeichnen und deshalb
bleibe ich dabei wir werden sicher
wissen
das sieht christoph schönig
möglicherweise etwas anders das werden
wir aber im laufe der sendung auch noch
diskutieren
ich sage jetzt mal anders was bleibt
denn von ihr positive in erinnerung
sie hat einen regierungsstil der dem
land gut getan hat vor allem nach dem
sehr anstrengenden regierungsstil von
rot-grün ich glaube darin lag schon viel
das sauberste den sehen sie da rein
gebracht hat bei den inhaltlichen
bilanzierung da kommen wir später darauf
welche etwas kritisch aber natürlich hat
diese ruhige art hat sie mit dieser
ruhigen art gepunktet und diese dieses
sehr sehr stabile nervenkostüm dass sie
verfügt kam dann noch dazu das sind
glaube ich die zwei eigenschaften die
ihr in dieser kanzlerschaft sehr
geholfen haben verbreitet gibt es den
einen größten fehler den sie gemacht hat
ja den gibt es die migrations krise und
das ist nicht die migrations krise wegen
der entscheidung die flüchtlinge vom
bahnhof in budapest 2015 im land
aufzunehmen sondern es ist das halbe
jahr danach es ist eine an meinen ein
fehler gewesen unvorbereitet die partei
das land die sicherheitsbehörden in
einer situation zu bringen in denen in
der die kontrolle uns vorsichtig
auszudrücken schwierig war es war ein
fehler für diese frage keine strategie
zu haben obwohl es ja das
migrationsproblem sich das ganze jahr
über aufgebaut hat und ich glaube es war
am ende auch ein fehler wieder einmal
das parlament nicht einzubinden nicht zu
befragen und eben den den die
legislative in dieser fundamentalen
frage eines landes so beiseite zu lassen
das scheint mir auch zu den mustern zu
gehören die schwierig sind bei der
bundeskanzlerin nämlich die die
gewaltenteilung nicht so respektiert zu
haben und nicht so gepflegt zu haben wie
das eigentlich einer demokratie in
deutschland nicht nur angemessen sondern
auch nötig gewesen auch ein thema das im
zusammenhang mit corona ja eine rolle
spielt wobei wenn ich es richtig sehe ja
zumindest die mangelnde vorbereitung auf
diese flüchtlingswelle
die kann ja inzwischen auch eingeräumt
hat der kirche nahm angela merkel ist ja
so eine art gegenentwurf zu vielen
politikern die um uns herum amtieren
boris johnson donald trump sebastian
kurz viktor orban auch emanuel makro
eigentlich
hat zieht die politische kultur die
politische kommunikation auch für die
zukunft geprägt wird da viel bleiben von
ihrem regierungsstil dass man sagen kann
nach diesem alt berühmten satz aus der
ddr von angela merkel lernen heißt
siegen lernen
das sind ja zwei verschiedene fragen das
eine ist die frage inwieweit sich die
politische rhetorik prägen wird die
andere feiern wie weil sie die
politische kultur prägen wird und da
habe ich eine ganz klare unterscheidung
ziehen
auf der einen seite es hat herr
schwenker gesagt diese ruhige besonnene
art dieses auch tatsächlich in
besonderen herausforderung diese ruhe
auszustrahlen
das ist sicherlich etwas was durchaus
attraktives und was er jetzt auch
durchaus wieder versucht wird seitens
von armin laschet was die politische
rhetorik angeht sie hat es sehr wohl
hinbekommen wirklich sehr prägnante
sätze zu sagen
ich erinnere an diesen satz die einlagen
der sparen und sparer sind sicher 2008
oder dieser satz markant auf den punkt
sie kennen mich oder aber auch 2009 10
es ist ernst nehmen sie es ernst hat es
geschafft ihre politik zu verdichten was
sie allerdings nicht geschafft hat ist
ihre politik konzise zu erklären und das
schließt auch an das an was frau
westermann gesagt hat dass es im
nachgang tatsächlichen mangel an
politischer kommunikation ja deswegen
wird von ihr in erinnerung bleiben dass
sie in bestimmten krisen sind die dinge
auf den punkt gebracht hat aber ihre
politik erklären und auch die
sinnstiftung die war bis auf in der
korona krise ersten pandemiewelle nicht
so optimal deswegen wird von der
politischen rhetorik nicht so viel übrig
bleiben und dass sie vorreiter feld
gemeint haben
die bleibende vielleicht noch mal bei
denen bei den bei dem was an etiketten
das ist so ein bisschen so angeklungen
mit jedem erfolgreichen langjährigen
regierungschefs in diesem land in der
geschichte den großen kanzlern verbindet
man einen begriff adenauer westbindung
brand ostverträge kohl deutsche einheit
gibt es da eigentlich schon entwürfe für
ein historisches etikett dass man der
bundeskanzlerin merkel ankleben könnte
also erst mal finde ich gehört der
vollständigkeit halber die agenda als
man sich zehn von gerhard schröder
zwingend und dringend damit dazu in
dieser aufzählung ich glaube dass dieses
land gerhard schröder sehr sehr viel zu
verdanken hat das hat ja die
bundeskanzlerin als übernommen hatte
auch konzediert dass er sich damit
verdient gemacht hat um dieses land bald
sie auch seine
in einer hart geführten grunde hat sie
geerntet was er gesät hat und seine
eigene partei hat ihnen dafür mehr oder
weniger zum teufel gejagt
auch bitte die wähler auch muss man
sagen stimmt und die endgültige bilanz
von frau merkel wird man deswegen auch
aus in einigen jahren ziehen können
genauso wie man das bei gerhard schröder
erst einige jahre später tun konnte aber
ich teile die einschätzung von
verwahrten feld das der der fehler den
sie da seinerzeit 215 folgende gemacht
hat das ist der eintrag ins
geschichtsbuch das wird davon übrig
bleiben
und all die folgen dieses gezeitigt hat
nicht zuletzt eine tiefe
gesellschaftliche spaltung die mit
sicherheit nicht daran alleine hin die
sich aber sehr stark daran
kristallisiert hat und bis heute
nachwirkt und einsatz nur noch wenn man
sich das wahlprogramm von armin laschet
durchliest es ist ein bisschen
anstrengend 139 seiten und nicht alles
ist der reine lesegenuss also man muss
ja lange durchhalten aber hinten raus
kommt da gerade in diesen fragen
eindeutig eine abkehr von merkels
migrationspolitik da steht ganz klar
gesteuert gezielt traf auch und clans
und all das also wer da jetzt in den
kommentaren geschrieben hat herr laschet
einfach die fortsetzung von frau merkel
mit anderen gesicht oder anderen
geschlecht das spiegelt sich finde ich
in diesem programm nicht wieder hat
genau gesehen da müssen wir die leute
zurückholen
da haben wir unsere eigene klientel
verloren aber ich glaube weil das auch
ganz gut wahlprogramm mit zu lesen ich
glaube dass ich glaube dass noch nicht
mal also selbst wenn man sagt es war ein
fehler ich glaube nicht dass es das ist
was von der kanzlerin in erinnerung
bleiben wird weil man muss sich ja noch
mal überlegen
deutschland hatte in den 90er jahren
schon mal eine wirklich dramatische
migrations krisen im während des
balkankriegs das ist alles total
vergessen also da gibt es noch so diese
etiketten rostock lichtenhagen an die
man denkt man an die an die übergriffe
auf flüchtlinge aber letztlich ist es
nicht das was mit der regierungszeit
helmut kohls in irgendeiner form
verbunden wird deshalb glaube ich wird
es stimmt es nicht ich glaube das was
kommt strahlend aber in den von angela
merkel hinein drohungen bleiben wird und
das ist wirklich ein großer und große
veränderung zu allen
dann vorher aussah zum helmut schmidt
das ist die art zu regieren zu eben
diese ruhe die sie genannt haben diese
überragende intelligenz die die sie hat
ich glaube es gab nie einen
intelligenteren kanzler gegeben als als
angela merkel aber vor allem diese das
dass sie eine rolle gefunden hat ohne
politische ziele zu regieren und
trotzdem eben einerseits agil zu sein in
krisen und das auch zu können und dann
angemessen zu reagieren und auf der
anderen seite eben in europa und
international bis jetzt vielleicht auf
die zeit von donald trump eine neue
rolle deutschlands in der welt gefunden
zu haben die eben nicht rein von der
nachkriegszeit geprägt ist die nicht von
dem deutsch französischen partners
geprägt ist sondern die eine moderation
rolle annimmt
eine selbstbewusste rolle in europa zu
spielen die aber für sich stehen kann
ich glaube dass das etwas ist was sie
wirklich zu eigentlich zur modernsten
politikerin des 21 eine neue rolle
deutschlands in der welt also den
außenpolitiker ganz kurz ein kirchner
kleinen moment das wird aber gleich
kommt gleich zu ihm ja also eine neue
rolle deutschlands in der welt dass wir
den außenpolitiker ruprecht polenz
natürlich besonders interessieren wir
sind ja noch bei der frage herr polenz
es geht um die entwürfe sollen
historisches etikett angela merkel ist
ja noch im amt aber wir suchen ja nach
begriffen für ihre kanzlerschaft da kann
man sich vielleicht jetzt schon auf die
suche machen
ihre amtszeit assoziiert bleiben wird
dass sich deutschland durch vier je nach
dem mann zelt auf fünf schwere krisen zu
führen hatte die welt finanzkrise
2007/2008 verbunden damit dann die
eurokrise und die verwerfungen innerhalb
des euroraums dann kam die
flüchtlingskrise da habe ich zu der
frage wann und wo der fehler gemacht
wurden eine etwas andere meinung nicht
teile hier die selbstkritik von frau
merkel die gesagt hat die fehler sind
eigentlich 2011 2012 2013 passiert wo
deutschland zu den ländern gehört hat
die gegen eine gemeinsame europäische
wirtschaftspolitik waren
gesagt hat er ablehnen da wir den dublin
und das ist das problem der außengrenzen
länder des schengen-raums das war der
fehler deshalb war man dann 2015 sehr
sehr schlecht vorbereitet und diese
aufgabe zu einer gemeinsamen asyl und
flüchtlingspolitik zu kommen die liegt
immer noch ungelöst auf den tisch und
vor dem hintergrund muss man sicherlich
auch die passagen jetzt das wahlprogramm
der unionsparteien lesen und was die
krisen angeht wir sind noch in der
korona pandemie und auch da denke ich
glaube mein unterm strich sagen können
durch alle diese krisen hat sie
deutschland vergleichsweise gut geführt
dass wird denke ich bleiben und
inwieweit einzelne punkte besonders
hervorstechen es ist sicherlich ihr
spiel
es ist das darf man und muss man
vielleicht heute leider auch dazu sagen
ihre skandal freiheit also viele von
denen mit denen sie als regierungschefin
zusammen gesessen hat haben ja hinterher
und teilweise auch wert ihrer amtszeiten
mit beträchtlichen skandalen zu tun gab
manche sind auch ins gefängnis gewandert
also wir konnten stolz auf meine
bundeskanzlerin sein die wirklich
skandalfrei was die persönliche
integrität angeht regiert hat der kirche
zahlen eine ganze reihe von legosteinen
schon mal gesammelt
es bleibt eigentlich immer so bei allen
beiträgen hier das vielleicht sogar das
etikett krisenkanzlerin ganz gut passen
würde jetzt muss man aber anders als
sagen nach der euro krise 2008 hat die
bundesrepublik deutschland unter ihrer
regierung einen gewaltigen
wohlstandszuwachs und ein
wirtschaftswachstum in nicht gekannter
form erlebt trotzdem krisenkanzlerin ist
das dann gerechtfertigt wenn wir uns mal
anschauen was genau davon ihren
erinnerung bleibt dann ist in der tat
dieses fremming krisenkanzlerin das
wollte mir absolut sicher bin dass das
in die geschichte eingehen wird nur wir
sollten uns an dieser stelle ja auch
vergegenwärtigen dass zum einen die
ungenügende finanzmarktregulierung dass
man sich auf die südeuropäischen länder
verlassen hat was sie darin zwei
abkommen ab angeht oder eben auch das
noch nicht genügend vorbereitung auf die
korona krise getroffen sagen wir es mal
so was das akt
diese vorbereiten was eine präventive
politik angeht dort hat sich sicherlich
versäumnis gehabt aber wenn es dann um
das reagieren ging in der krise
souveränität zu zeigen dann ist das ja
wohl passiert teils allerdings lassen
europäischen partnerinnen und partner
und wenn wir uns zum beispiel corona
krise anschauen sagen wir mal so wenn
wir auf die kanzlerin gehört hätten und
nicht die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
einige beschlüsse verbessert hätte dann
wären wir dann noch deutlich besser
durchgekommen
als das der fall war war sie als
physikerin das ganz natürlich verstanden
hat aber ich möchte doch auf einführung
zurückkommen was die außenpolitik angeht
ich denke nicht dass angela merkel will
endlich eine ära begründet hat weil sie
einfach ein programmatisches defizit hat
weil sie ja nicht wirklich ganz genau
sagt wo sie hin will sondern mit einer
politik der mäßigung der moderation und
der bewussten mitte agiert und
gleichzeitig sollten wir zur kenntnis
nehmen wenn der polnische außenminister
radoslaw sikorski sagt er fürchtet
deutsche führung deutlich weniger als
deutsche untätigkeit dann selbst der
ehemalige stellvertretende israelische
aussenminister sagt er wünscht sich
deutschland als europäische
führungsmacht ja als ein global leader
wenn sie selber vom forbes magazin
tatsächlich zehn mal als mächtigste frau
der welt betrachtet wird dann kann man
eines sagen ungeplant hat sie
tatsächlich außenpolitisch deutschland
auch deutlich verändert und für mich
persönlich macht sich das in folgenden
faktor fest wir sind das land der
täterinnen und täter und wir wurden
unter dieser herrschaft zum beliebtesten
land der welt gewählt daran hat
sicherlich auch das sommermärchen die
nationalmannschaft und anteil aber immer
auch angela merkel mit ihrem mäßigen
investieren eines muss man sagen ihre
reputation im ausland ist der größere
als hierzulande auch aus verständlichen
gründen
das hat sich ins von der doktorwürde in
harvard gezeigt gut jetzt haben wir ja
die über schlechte umfragewerte hier
jetzt persönlich auch nicht in
deutschland sie kann sich da auch nicht
beklagen ich sehe den punkt mit der
krisenkanzlerin etwas anders und auch
stellte ihn in frage denn also
zugespitzt gesagt krise ist immer wenn
wir den kanzler vorher plötzlich hat er
es zu tun mit zwei einstürzenden
riesigen türmen in new york und dem der
auslösung des bündnisses in der nato
artikel 5 und findet sich vor einer
bücherwand wieder so ähnlich wie die von
der wir herrn polens hier sehen und er
muss die solidarität erklären also es
das ist immer und was ich ihr
tatsächlich verhalten würde ist das was
bei allen kirchen anklang
sie hat reagiert aber nicht regiert das
heißt in all diesen punkten in denen
reformbedarf besteht
pflege andere bereiche da ist in dieser
regierungszeit wenig bis nichts passiert
und deswegen ist es im moment für die
union auch ein ziemlich schwierig jetzt
immer vom aufbruch zu sprechen zu sagen
wir müssen die digitale welt und so
weiter wenn du 16 jahre regiert hast
dann klingt das etwas seltsam wenn man
jetzt plötzlich sagt wir müssen endlich
den digitalen aufbruch schaffen also
deswegen wäre ich da etwas weniger milde
als die runde insgesamt was die was die
das resümee anlangt ich glaube dass das
natürlich die bahn als größter kirche
hatte frau wirkt eine krise tritt auf
und es gibt jemanden der reagiert es
gibt jemanden der das kann wobei es eben
auch mal besser und mal schlechter
gelaufen ist in krisen
das erstaunliche ist eben nur dass die
krisen die sie von anfang an auf dem
zettel hatte die klimakrise angela
merkel war als war umweltministerin in
den 90er jahren hat das kyoto-protokoll
vorbereiter einigen damen hat sich an
gewisse muss man sie hat mit
heiligendamm angefangen also sie hat
diese in die klimakrise glaube ich
ernster genommen als jeder andere
politiker auf früher ernst genommen als
jeder andere politikerin
dennoch hat sie nicht gehandelt weil sie
nicht handeln musste und dasselbe gilt
übrigens und das wird uns in der
nächsten legislaturperiode dann auf die
füße fallen
es geht dasselbe gilt für die
rentenversicherung also
pflegeversicherung ist peanuts gegen das
was in der rentenversicherung versäumt
worden ist in den letzten zehn jahren
weil es eben keinen großen
handlungsdruck gab weil man nicht wusste
und weil man eben das gefühl hat es geht
schon noch irgendwie dieses problem muss
jetzt oder muss in den nächsten jahren
gelöst werden und das wird ganz bitter
werden dafür kurz ein haken bevor wir zu
herrn kirchner kommt sie haben das
stichwort klima genannt zu diesem thema
hat sie sich heute im bundestag bei der
befragung auch geäußert und wir wollen
uns zur klimapolitik auf eine frage aus
dem kreis der abgeordneten und wir
wollen uns diese diese äußerungen diese
noten der kanzlerin mal anhören
die zeit drängt wahnsinnig
und ich kann die ungeduld der jungen
leute verstehen also genug ist es
angesichts der objektiven situation noch
nicht aber es ist viel passiert und mit
einem höheren tempo als 1997 sozusagen
auf der agenda stand ja das heißt also
sie haben gerade gesagt sie hat das
thema klima eigentlich schon erkannt als
wichtiges thema thema ein ihr thema
jetzt sagt sie das gleich viel zu wenig
passiert aber sie ist ja kann somit
bestimmt zwar die richtlinien der
politik aber sie kann sich nicht allein
bestimmt hat eben die harvard rede der
kanzlerin zieht luther wirklich
lesenswert ist von 2009 10
und da sagt sie einen satz der einen und
nach läuft sie sagt nämlich in dieser
rede
ich habe muss mich immer fragen tue ich
die dinge weil sie möglich sind oder
weil sie richtig sind und natürlich legt
sie in dieser rede vor den studenten den
studenten nach du die dinge weil sie
richtig sind tut wo das was richtig ist
wenn man der kanzlerin wirklich etwas
vorwerfen würde würde ich sagen ist es
dass sie die dinge getan hat die möglich
fahren und für die dinge die sie für
richtig gehalten hat und die sie für
richtig hält nicht ausreichend geworben
hat dafür hat sie ihre politische
karriere nicht riskiert moritz kölner
bitte also ich meine es gibt ja einen
politischen stil den die kanzlerin
wirklich kultiviert hat dieses modeling
früh also das heißt dieses durchwursteln
das heißt auf sich zufahren zu schauen
welche probleme es gibt die dann
entsprechend anzugehen und da bin ich
sehr bei der analyse die jetzt kam denn
sie hat ja angekündigt der
klimakanzlerin zu sein ich erinnere mich
auch an dieses bild wo sie 2007 in grün
anstand und das herzlich wenig passiert
ist muss man einfach ganz klar so sagen
und das was wir zum o ton gehört haben
das hat das bundesverfassungsgericht der
wirklich um die ohren gehauen also
anders kann man es wirklich nicht
betonen und da muss ich sagen ist auch
eine gewisse scheinheiligkeit
das muss an dieser stelle sein und auch
was das thema digitalisierung angeht der
killer sie hatten es ja angesprochen
dieses versprechen ja das land das land
moderat zu regieren nicht zu viel
veränderung zuzumuten das ist natürlich
ein dort auf die füße gefahren ich sage
ihnen ganz offen für mich war der
paradigmatische moment von ihr dieser
satz sie kennen mich und stück weit auch
immer dieses versprechen
ich halte so die unbedingt in der welt
geht von den leuten ab es ist die
möglichkeit dass man sich wohlfühlt das
auch ein stück weit eine
entpolitisierung stattfindet
der preis den wir dafür gezahlt haben
ist die langfristige gestaltung und was
ich sehe ist dass der aktuelle
aufschwung die die grünen haben auch
damit zu tun hat dass es ein bedürfnis
gibt darüber nachzudenken was einem ein
morgen sein könnte was vielleicht auch
wirklich eine gesellschaftliche
erzählung ist die über das hier und
jetzt hinaus trägt und da muss man ganz
klar sagen
der nachteil ihrer reaktiven politik war
eben genau das dass sie dortmund auf
einen sinn defizite produziert hatten
und alleine schon sich wirklich
vorzunehmen asymmetrisch zudem
mobilisieren ist etwas was man die auch
vorwerfen kann dass sie tatsächlich
bewusst versucht hat mich zu
politisieren sondern zu entpolitisieren
polen sie sagt also den studenten
inhaber tut nicht nur das was möglich
ist sondern auch das was richtig ist
aber jetzt war der frau sie hat eben
doch nur das getan was möglicher das
passt ja eigentlich auch zu den
politischen aufgabe dass politik immer
noch die kunst des möglichen ist ja das
wäre der ersatz gewesen folgert er mir
auch eingefallen ist als das jetzt
gerade so gesagt wurde
es bleibt schon so dass politik die
kunst des möglichen ist aber richtig ist
natürlich auch dass politik die aufgabe
hat die menschen von dem notwendigen zu
überzeugen damit sie es dann in einer
demokratie mit der notwendigen
mehrheiten möglich machen ich frag mich
aber schon wenn ich jetzt der diskussion
dazu gehört habe welche sozusagen durch
griffs erwartungen an eine kanzlerin
oder an einen kanzler gestellt werden
wir leben in einem föderalen staat
demokratisch organisiert sehr viele
gesetze sind zustimmungspflichtig das
heißt sie brauchen auch eine mehrheit im
bundesrat
und damit sind wir quasi bei vielen
wichtigen fragen meine art all parteien
region in deutschland in der praxis wir
leben glücklicherweise dass wir hier ja
auch niemand in einem system wie china
wo natürlich der präsident der
gleichzeitig generalsekretär der
kommunistischen partei ist auf
lebenszeit jetzt im amt dinge durch
stellen kann der kann sozusagen china
gestalten
wenn man sich anschaut wie stark solche
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten einer ganzen
gesellschaft
demokratien sind fällt mir im augenblick
nur mit thatcher ein den der britischen
demokratie sicherlich die gesellschaft
sehr stark verändert hat ich will jetzt
gar nicht über den preis regeln und ob
das richtig war aber darauf verweisen
dass es schon zu deutschland zwei
wesentliche unterschiede gibt
großbritannien hat ein
mehrheitswahlrecht was maggie thatcher
mit 40 prozent der stimmen ermöglicht
hat mit der deutlichen absoluten
mehrheit im parlament zu reagieren und
großbritannien ist in dem sinne kein
föderaler staat war hier also von daher
sind weder die verdienste noch die
kritik so allein bei einer person finde
ich persönlich in deutschland abzuladen
wie man jetzt vielleicht gefallen dürfte
wirbelte er anmerkt arbeiten fällt dann
gesucht und ich glaube sie haben schon
recht polens wenn sie uns ermahnen dass
wir respektieren sollen und müssen dass
es nicht nur die exekutive also nicht
nur die regierung sondern auch die
legislative und zunehmend ja auch die
gerichtsbarkeit gibt die deutschland
gestalten und die die politik in diesem
land gestalten aber ich glaube dass
angela merkel in den 16 jahren
tatsächlich so etwas wie eine
präsidialkanzlerin geworden ist wir
haben zwar kein direktes wahlrecht wir
haben starkes parlament unter kleiner
hat zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass
alles was wir tun
vor der vor der folie passiert ist
deutschland den zweiten weltkrieg und
der nationalsozialismus angezettelt hat
und dass deshalb natürlich die deutsche
verfassung anders aussehen muss als die
als die englische die amerikanische und
die französische dennoch hat die
kanzlerin sozusagen in den 16 jahren die
stunde der exekutive die man in krisen
ja immer aus ruft da muss die regierung
sofort handeln so ausgedehnt dass die
eigene cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion ihren
vertrauten volker kauder nach hause
geschickt hat und zwar nicht freundlich
und mit dankesworten sondern wirklich
ekelhaft vom hof gejagt hat weil die das
gefühl hatten wir sind in diesen damals
14 jahren regierungszeit angela merkel
so viel zu kurz gekommen das parlament
die fraktion die legislative ist so
beschränkt und entmachtet worden
das dass sie sich gerächt haben
und ich glaube das muss man sehr ernst
nehmen die kanzlerin hat möglicherweise
gerade in krisen aber auch zwischendrin
stärker entscheidungen geprägt als viele
kanzler vorher das föderale geflecht was
herr polenz hat zurecht geschrieben hat
ganz klar mit ja
betraf alle regierungschefs dieses
landes und trotzdem haben es einige
geschafft dinge hinzukriegen wirklich
also große sachen zu schaffen
wenn ein bundeskanzler ist schafft eine
meiner bevölkerung zu sagen wir werden
künftig nicht mehr diese währung haben
sondern aus diesen und jenen gründen
eine gemeinsame währung haben dass es
eine eine ganz ganz große leistung ein
ganz großes verdienst egal wie man jetzt
zu dieser währung steht aber das ist das
ist wirklich bergauf das ist politik
verkaufen wer das schafft hat meinen
hohen respekt das gleiche gilt für einen
sozialdemokratischen kanzler der eine
agenda 2010 machte das ist nämlich auch
bergauf gegen die eigene gegen die
eigenen leute in der eigenen partei und
das fehlt mir das tut mir leid komplett
war angela merkel
sie hat die dinge er erlitten als
gestaltet ich räume ein vieles im
erleiden dann gut gemanagt manchmal auch
erratische entscheidungen getroffen die
eine höhe genannt die andere war für
mich den von ihr verlängerten
atomausstieg oder hinausgezögert
atomausstieg dann nochmal zu
radikalisieren in einer form wie sie ich
glaube ich ihrem trittin nicht hätte
träumen lassen als er den ursprünglichen
atomausstieg organisiert hatte
also da sind auch einige erotische
entscheidungen dabei in meinen augen
es gibt in einem anderen in einer
anderen biografie ist der von frau
weidenfeld den satz dass sie gesagt hat
ich stand damals als junges mädchen fünf
meter brett und musste immer sehr lange
überlegen war es nun drei meter 3 also
gut drei meter brett aber jedenfalls auf
dem sprungbrett im schwimmbad und hat
sich also lange brücke springen oder
nicht und es gibt halt in der politik
manchmal situationen da hast du nicht
diese lange zeit darüber nachzudenken
ja aber manchmal ins leere becken würde
ich sagen kirchner
also ich möchte an dieser stelle herrn
ständige widersprechen weil der punkt
ist auch der sie hat es geschafft es hat
im vierten 11 sehr schön gesagt ich
hatte gesagt deutschland ist der quasi
hier gewohnt in europa der independent
hat das gesagt wir sind der
unfreiwillige wohnen und was sie beide
eben in dem fall aus politischer
perspektive die er polen reingebracht
hat gesagt haben ist der große
unterschied ist dass man keine angst
mehr haben muss und das ist ja gerade in
der historischen vergleich etwas was er
durchaus eben von deutschland ausging
dass sich die anderen länder vor uns
gefürchtet haben und diese wirklich
diese reputation sicher arbeitet zwar
durch diesen ruhigen verlässlichen stil
das ist das eine was von ihr bleibt und
es kommt was anders sind zusätzlich die
frage was ist so der maßstab was ist die
referenz linie und das hatten sie auch
schon in der anmoderation gesagt herr
keller
es haben sich ja maßstäbe verschoben wir
haben präsidenten erlebt die bewusst
gelogen haben wir haben präsidenten
erlebt er offen sich gegen das gesetz
verstoßen haben wir haben es erlebt dass
menschen in verantwortung gesagt offen
bestätigt waren
und das ist wiederum der punkt wo angela
merkel gewirkt hat denn man kann sehr
über ihre politik streiten dann kann das
auch so sehen wer ständig aber es gibt
drei dinge die man ihr definitiv nicht
an sagen kann erstens sie warten nicht
bestechlich
zweitens hat die dinge eben sehr
rational gemacht auch sehr nüchtern und
sie hat zumindest in den allermeisten
fällen auch ein hohes maß an
verlässlichkeit gehabt und damit hat sie
als person aber auch in der
symbolpolitik ein enormes gegengewicht
zu den tramp sagt wo sind andere der
welt geliefert und das ist etwas was aus
meiner sicht bleibt jeder mensch ändert
in den 16 jahren wahrscheinlich ab und
zu seine meinung aber zusagen
verlässlich wenn jemand im jahr 2011
öffentlich sagt zu meinen lebzeiten wird
es keine gemeinschaftsschulden geben und
im jahr 2020 aus einer aus anderer
begründung aber gemeinschaftsschulden
zustimmt dakar also ich glaube die
verlässlichkeit der kanzlerin ist das
ist ihre lernfähigkeit oder ihre ihre
fähigkeit wandelnde einsichten dann am
ende auch so zu präsentieren als sei es
seine single ihre amtsträger hat gesagt
was interessiert mich mein geschwätz von
gestern
ja aber es hat sie ja nicht gesagt sie
hat gesagt also sie hat ja immer dass
das ist ja das was herr kirchner sagt
sie kennen mich eben diese aura der
verlässlichkeit der stetigkeit um sich
verbreitet und hat dann aber unbemerkt
in vielen punkten ihre meinung zu 180
grad gedreht angela merkel war mal
familienministerin und hat damals die
ehe von mann und frau für sakrosankt
erklärt innerhalb auch der cdu und die
hat sie in einem in einem einem gespräch
mit einer frauenzeitschrift im
öffentlichen mittags gespräch sagen
abgeräumt als thema ich will nur den
also ich will gar nicht sagen aber es
ist falsch
respektlos über die kanzlerin schafft
von angela merkel reden aber
verlässlichkeit würde ich sagen ist
jetzt ist ein ist ein etikett das
funktioniert hat aber dass durch die
tatsache nur mäßig gedeckt ist dann
würde ich nur eines noch gerne
ergänzungs die maßstäbe nicht
verrutschen also der umstand dass sie
nicht korrupt ist und auch nicht
korrumpierbar ich teile das übrigens
weil ihr auch materielle sachen gar
nichts bedeuten macht sehr viel
materielles sachen sehr wenig aber der
umstand dass sie sich nicht als korrupte
politik entschuldigung das würde ich
jetzt als selbstverständlichkeit erstmal
leben und dass das anderswo anders ist
ist sehr traurig aber das kann doch
jetzt nicht das maß der dinge sein und
dass man deswegen ist sie schon eine
ganz große kanzlerin gewesen ist wenn
sie am fest wendige sie haben gerade
herrn schröder so gelobten seine agenda
ja und dann werde ich einmal daran
erinnern dass die wesentlichen teile der
damaligen opposition der ich im
parlament noch angehört habe mitgetragen
worden sind und wie man sein engagement
jetzt nach dem ende der kanzlerschaft
beurteilt da können wir uns gerne in
einer anderen sitzung darüber
unterhalten sind wir wahrscheinlich gar
nicht andere meinung haben
berufen sind so sitzt also das mit der
frage lässt sich jemand einkaufen ja
oder nein
dass das so zu sagen so weit weg vom
deutschen kanzlerin wäre das würde ich
nicht sagen
herr polenz hat er war dass der begriff
angela merkel und macht gerade schon
noch mal viel hat alba berlin ein eher
nüchternes oder ein ähnliches verhältnis
zu machen ich glaube dass die generell
sehr schwer kopfgesteuert ist wenn ich
das mal so ausdrücken da und die dinge
sehr stark analysiert es war für mich
als jurist auch faszinierend zu sehen
die naturwissenschaftler denken das ist
nochmal ein durchaus andere denkansatz
in der einen oder anderen frage und es
ist ja vorhin schon gesagt worden dass
ihr diese fähigkeit auch sehr zupass
gekommen ist und dazu eben auch das
spiel die frage der verlässlichkeit da
würde ich gern auch noch was dazu sagen
ich glaube die menschen vertrauen auch
nur den politiker in den sie zutrauen
lernfähig zu sein und nicht denen so
nach dem motto du hast mir aber doch vor
zehn jahren gesagt es gibt keine
gemeinschaftsschulden und deshalb
blockiert du jetzt ancona aufbau von der
europäischen union der dringend nötig
ist es ist doch klar gewesen dass sich
in diese entwicklung jetzt europa auch
für die länder engagieren muss die das
mit dem wiederaufbau nach der pandemie
nicht alleine stemmen können und dass
das geld irgendwo herkommen muss und da
ist eben für diesen begrenzten effekt
jetzt diese gemeinschafts möglichkeit
geschaffen worden
also das widerspricht nicht
verlässlichkeit mit verlaub gesagt
sondern ich glaube dass menschen das von
der politik erwarten politik ist ein
bisschen nicht das bild noch los werden
darf die fahrrad fahren wenn man gar den
lenker starkes liegt man auf die nase
man muss immer ein bisschen nach steuern
muss ein ziel haben eher kinder und
weitere theorie wenn ja bitte
also es kommt ja noch was kann es kommt
ja was ganz was anderes hinzu wofür
wofür sie nichts an den bmhs dass sie
eine frau ist
das ist für sich erstmal noch durch das
besondere aber sie war auch ein
rollenmodell für viele andere frauen und
wir dürfen auch nicht ganz vergessen
dass gerade viele junge menschen jetzt
in diesem land auf was sie kennen gar
nichts anderes als die kanzlerin merkel
und das wiederum heißt dass ihr
machtinstinkt ja und sicherlich auch
diese fähigkeit daneben auch wirklich
lange zeit an der regierung zu sein
einen kollateral nutzen hat den sie
sicherlich so gar nicht vorhergesehen
hat nämlich dass es jetzt für junge
menschen durchaus selbstverständnis eben
zweifel eben auch solche sollten eine
führungsposition herbei zurück und sie
hat eben auch ganz offenkundig gezeigt
wirklich als persönliches beispiel dass
auch frauen das spiel der macht
beherrschen den mann erinnern wir uns
daran wen sie alles wenn man das mal so
mit verlaub sagen darf weggebissen hat
oder gegen wen sich durchgesetzt hat das
heißt für die modernisierung
von geschlechter beziehung hat sie
obwohl sie sich nicht aktiv zum
feminismus bekannt hat doch einiges
getan und das wird mich wiederum zu dem
punkt dass ihr denke am ende wenn wir
uns die geschichtsbücher anschauen wird
man sagen merkel hat nicht unbedingt
auch bestimmte dinge gezielt aber
unfreiwillig hat sie doch bestimmte
dinge erreicht die von ihr durch das in
erinnerung bleiben werden und dazu wird
eine gewisse form der emanzipation der
macht definitiv dazu gehört das hat bei
der befragung der kanzlerin im bundestag
auch eine abgeordnete gesagt jetzt als
erzieherin gearbeitet hat dass die
hälfte ihrer klasse jetzt gern kanzlerin
werden wollte ich würde gerne noch einen
anderen aspekt und das spielt sich jetzt
auch mit dem thema frau eine woche lang
eine rolle
ein csu politiker als er sich über
angela merkel mal unglaublich ausgelegt
hat sie ja mit dem sport so nennt
wachtel bedacht mit diesem wort hat sie
ja später selbst kokettiert
eine frau aus dem osten in einer männer
beherrschten partei aus dem westen wie
es die cdu eigentlich bis heute noch ist
das klingt nach politischen dynamit ist
dieses verhältnissen so richtig
ausbalanciert worden ist es nicht und es
hat viel glaube ich mit der geschichte
der deutschen wiedervereinigung unter
bände zu tun angela merkel ist ja wie
viele wissen eher zufällig in der cdu
gelandet also wie ist 1989 mit ihrem
damaligen chef zu verschiedenen parteien
gegangen und bei den sozis wurde sie
geduzt das hat ja nicht gepasst und bei
den grünen und den alternativen und dem
neuen forum da wurde viel geredet aber
nichts entschieden das fand sie auch
blöd und dann ist sie zum demokratischen
aufbruch gegangen und der wiederum ist
dann am ende durch eine verheerende
stasi affäre ihres vorsitzenden
überschuldung wolfgang fluhr in der in
der in der cdu gelandet das war also
alles totaler zufall
und das ist glaube ich auch eine
kränkung die cdu ihr bis heute nicht
vergisst es hätte jede andere partei
auch sein können und der zweite große
zufall oder das zweite große die zweite
große denn die geschichte war die 1999
in die spendenaffäre der cdu helmut kohl
ging unter in dieser spendenaffäre und
fast jeder der damaligen möglichen
kandidaten für den parteivorsitz
wolfgang
aber die anderen auch hatten irgendwie
eine verwicklung eine geschichte
entweder mit helmut kohl oder mit der
spendenaffäre oder mit beidem
insofern ist angela merkel als
generalsekretär in der cdu war die
einzige die erstens nicht belastet war
und die zweitens auch frei war
diesen brief in der alte oder diesen
diesen artikel in der faz zu schreiben
am 22 dezember dass die cdu laufen
lernen müssen dass sie sich von ihren
alten schlachtrösser emanzipieren müssen
das konnten die anderen nicht das konnte
nur angela merkel und das führte dann
dazu dass sie eigentlich aus dem zur
überraschung aller cdu-vorsitzende
geworden ist und danach dann ja eben
erst mal nicht kanzlerkandidatin 2002 in
wolfratshausen auf frühstück edmund
stoiber die kandidatur überlassen und
dann 2005 war sie ihn nicht mehr zu
nehmen insofern ab das waren zufälle das
waren viele dinge die sie in der cdu
eigenes zu einer ganz ganz
unwahrscheinlichen parteivorsitzenden
gemacht hat zu raten zu einer ganz
unwahrscheinlichen kanzlerkandidatin und
daneben auch zu einer unwahrscheinlichen
kanzlerin und das ist ja in der politik
sagt manja ist der dankbarkeit keine
kategorie die man erwarten kann aber was
mich immer etwas wundert ist die kanzel
über 18 jahre lang parteivorsitzende 16
jahre war die kanzlerin gewesen sich ja
der cdu zu einer unglaublich langen
regierungszeit und damit auch zu viel
einfluss auch zu vielen ämtern und
mandaten verholfen aber manche in der
cdu nicht nur der werte union haben sie
das gefühl diese frau war eigentlich
schon immer ein störfaktor die muss so
schnell wie möglich weg wieso kann man
jemand der so viel erfolg hatte so
bewerten dass man eigentlich diese jahre
bei manchen wie gesagt hat man das
gefühl dass das acht oder sechzehn
verlorene jahre für die maya das hat mit
dem zu tun was ich vorhin im
zusammenhang mit dem wahlprogramm
angesprochen habe weil sie natürlich
schon weite teile des wesens kerns der
cdu entweder platt gemacht hat oder
beiseite gedrängt hat da kann man jetzt
darüber streiten ob das richtig war
weil die cdu modernisiert werden musste
oder man kann sagen da sind viele
verloren gegangen die eigentlich in die
cdu gehören und jetzt vielleicht
anderswo ein problematischer stelle ihr
glück suchen und vielleicht auch finden
also das hat damit sehr viel zu tun dass
dieser im kern konservative kreis in der
cdu bei ihr einfach nicht heimisch wurde
und jetzt wird herr polenz gleich noch
mehr mit dem kopf schütteln als ich
jetzt schon ausgelöst habe aber es ist
schon erstaunlich
ich will gar nicht rechtfertigen was er
maßen alles twittert und und sagt und
postet und so weiter aber so einer wie
hans-georg maßen der sich jetzt
rechtfertigen muss in der thüringer
landesverband auch dass in der cdu da
kandidiert wäre vor der merkel-cdu
selbstverständlich kernbestand der cdu
gewesen und sagen wir mal karin prien
die bildungsministerin aus
schleswig-holstein er mich also dass und
jetzt ist es aber verschoben jetzt ist
karin prien mittendrin und herr maßen
steht unter verdacht doch eigentlich
eher der afg zuzuneigen kleinen moment
geduld er kirch ein kleiner mensch
gedulden doch wieder polenz hat die cdu
mit angela merkel gefremdelt und
vielleicht auch angela merkel mit der
cdu
wie gesagt ja westdeutsch
männerdominiert ist also die cdu wählt
wie andere parteien auch ihre
vorsitzenden alle zwei jahre und auf
eine amtszeit von zwei jahren können
also 18 jahre und die uns vorsitzende
ist ist man einmal wiedergewählt worden
und das ist nun kein zufall das war auch
kein zufall dass frau merkel beim
demokratischen aufbruch gelandet ist sie
haben ja gerade auch geschildert dass
sie andere geprüft hat wie man das eben
macht bevor man sich politisch irgendwo
weiter engagiert ob was anderes in frage
kommt ich habe das früher auch gemacht
also mir war die cdu nicht in die wiege
gelegt und ich habe mich eben umgeschaut
und orientiert und dann entschieden und
dass der demokratische aufbruch den weg
genommen hat den er genommen hat ist
richtig die eine hälfte des pa ist bei
der cdu gelandet die andere hälfte des
ta überwiegend bei der spd
ich habe das am beispiel von jena wo wir
den demokratischen aufbruch
seinerzeit unterstützt haben von münster
aus selber beobachten können und was die
frage des eu vorsitzes angeht nach
helmut kohl und wolfgang schäuble
da ist diskutiert worden brauchen wir
wollen wenn ich lieber einen übergangs
vorstellen dann übergangsvorsitzender
haben da waren bernhard vogel und kombi
den kopf im gespräch die beide
sicherlich nichts mit der spendenaffäre
zu tun hatten
aber man hat sich eben vor allem
neuanfang entschieden und zur angela
merkel und das mit dem fremdeln
ja sicher wenn ich daran denke wie
verwurzelt sich dadurch in der union
will dass ich erzählt der es
landesvorsitzende war im landesvorstand
einer jungen union
ich habe sozusagen in meiner biografie
die ja erst mit 48 jahren im bundestag
geführt hat ganz viele kontakte
deutschlandweit gehabt in der union
das hat vor merkel alles nicht haben
können weil sie eben erst 1990 in der
cdu war sie angefangen hat
da haben sie 15 jahre sozusagen union
gefehlt und das dass zu bestimmten
reaktion führt die kennen wir nicht so
genau weil mit der waren wir ja noch
nicht in der jungen union zusammen das
halte ich für ziemlich naheliegend erst
einmal und es kommt sicherlich zu ihrem
naturell dazu deswegen und nicht
diejenige ist die schulter klopft
sozusagen von einem tisch auf dem
bundesparteitag oder zum nächsten läuft
das sieht das vielleicht auch etwas
kühler erst mal auch an der bewirkt aber
der erfolg und das was sie aus der union
gemacht hat nämlich eine moderne
volkspartei auf der höhe der zeit der
gibt ihr recht
herr kirchner also dabei gerne nochmal
ein hack und tatsächlich auch mal zwei
perspektiven beleuchten
also im handy kommt er selber aus einem
pfarrer aus halt und dieses christliche
das ist ja schon in mir drin und wir
vergessen ganz gerne aber der cdu dass
ihre wurzeln nicht um gegen ihre politik
dass man sich ganz klar zu sagen aber
die wurzeln ja schon in diesen
christlichen wurzeln und gleichzeitig
wenn er sie war schon immer eine sehr
pragmatische person war schon immer eine
person die nicht unbedingt die großen
programmatischen reden geschwungen hat
sondern dieses grundprinzip der output
legitimation zu sagen
entscheidend ist das was am ende dabei
rauskommt und wenn er das ist doch genau
das was die union auszeichnet also ich
würde sagen nicht unbedingt vielleicht
was die inhalte angeht aber aus den stil
angeht weise wie politik gemacht wird
auch eben sehr rational das ist etwas wo
sie schon durchaus zu union passt
allerdings ich bin nicht so optimistisch
wie abholen ist jetzt am ende denn und
da kann ich durchaus die analyse von
herrn ständige noch erteilen
dadurch dass sie eben ihre politik
häufig nicht erklärt hat oder nicht
genügend erklärt hat vielleicht auch
nicht erklärt hat warum sie bestimmte
wechsel vollzogen hat die wir heute
diskutiert haben ist natürlich auch die
cdu nach innen verunsichert worden
und eines ist auch kleiner macht partei
mit der cdu geht es ja diese vorstellung
das kannste das dass die kanzlerin auch
parteivorsitzender was aber gleichzeitig
impliziert dass sie gar nicht die kraft
und die möglichkeit hat auf die
befindlichkeiten die wünsche der partei
einzugehen und das möchte ich an dieser
stelle schon sagen also die cdu ist so
wie sich jetzt auf stellt tatsächlich
programmatisch und personell ein stück
weit entfernt aber in einer möchte herrn
schwenniger definitiv widersprechen auch
vor merkel wäre herr maßen der jetzt
zunehmend wirklich
verschwörungstheoretiker positionen
vertritt eine randfigur gewesen und das
auch gut so gut ich habe jetzt noch so
viele fragen und wir sind am ende der
sendung allerdings vermutlich mal bis
zum endgültigen abgang im spätherbst
werden wir noch mehrfach dieses thema
haben vielleicht auch mit ihnen ich
bedanke mich bei ruprecht polenz bei
moritz kirchner bei ursula weidenfeld
und bei christoph schwennicke time sie
bei uns
[Musik]